pack up your pajamas and bust out your
ironing board the era of remote work
looks to be over Zoom the company that
sparked the whole work home work from
home craze is now requiring employees
within 50 miles of a company office to
come back to the cubicle again at least
two days a week they call it quote
unquote more effective for their bottom
line
Katie you seem to have some visceral
recipes this is this something uh did
you use zoom a lot no I actually hate
Zoom I would rather talk on the phone
than do a zoom call but I think asking
people to come to the office for the
sake of coming to the office without a
real purpose or just saying an arbitrary
number like two days a week is actually
inefficient for a lot of remote workers
I was talking to this young woman
yesterday she's a software engineer for
Amazon and she's like I'll go to the
office and I waste so much time because
everyone's talking everyone's at the
water cooler I just need to sit at my
desk for a certain period of time
without interruption and get my job done
and the commuting takes up so much of
people's time and life that they're like
you know what I don't want to do that
anymore so I I think it has to be job
dependent and there has to be a purpose
for it prime time some of the best
feedback I get is from these impersonal
casual spontaneous conversations at the
water cooler and I'll just be hanging
out and someone will go Jesse you know
maybe it wasn't a good idea to show a
zebra getting gunned down on TV uh maybe
Jesse you shouldn't use the word blow
when you say White House cocaine it
sounds like you're too familiar with the
narcotic
um oftentimes I'll just like pop my head
out of my office to my pod if I have an
epiphany I'll say I want the banner to
read the Secret Service blows White
House cocaine investigation and everyone
just loves it
script and she'll look at me and then
just roll her eyes and I know I'm going
to take it out of the script also if I
can see my producer sometimes I can
smell fear you see in his eyes he's
scared of losing his job and he looks at
me like I'm a kamikaze pilot and
sometimes I recognize the humanity in my
producers when I'm in the room alone
with them and then I pull back and I say
you know what we'll live to fight
another day that type of collaboration
in person you don't get over Zoom you
experience the same kind of
collaboration
exclamation point well you know when it
comes to community commuting I go back
and forth
[Laughter]
okay like I get Zoom saying Zoom saying
that you have to go back to work it's
like Ronald McDonald saying lay off the
fries right so you know it's they if
they're having a hard time but the
problem is man commuting just kills the
energy you have like right I'm leaving
for work I'm feeling great I'm Luke
Skywalker by the time I get to the
office here I'm Darth Vader like
Something's Happened along the way I'm
angry I'm just I'm violently mad my back
is my back has been killing me all day
welcome to the club yeah and it's like I
could have done this I could have done
the five from from uh the bed that would
have been amazing maybe that's maybe we
have to do YouTube yes
and call it boom bedroom
yeah
it's Monday uh Dana you working in the
White House working here you had your
own company is this something you would
want and you see value in the zoom all
right value it's weird because I I I
understand the need for some flexibility
for some people and I think that for
especially for a lot of working moms
they were like asking for this kind of
flexibility for a long time however a
couple of things I'm not exactly
persuaded by people saying well the
cities are dying so you have to come
back to the office like to me that's the
wrong incentive like what is the like if
the city's dying then you guys need to
change your policies you need to figure
out something else
um I did talk to a psychotherapist this
weekend she's a friend not I'm not a
patient how are things going um thank
you and to solve that problem talks to a
lot of young girls thank you she talks
to a lot of younger workers who she said
have tremendous anxiety about going back
to the office and she thinks that it's
compounded by the fact that they're
alone at their homes and then on they're
alone with their phones and it's they're
so isolated and she thinks that you know
a lot of young people now they're really
worried about their mental health or
concerned about their mental health she
thinks one of the best things that they
could do for their well-being and their
mental health is to be around some
people and collaborate and have some of
those fun moments when you know Jesse
says should I put this in the script you
say don't do it
fair enough always don't do it no one
ever says do it whatever I do I gave
permission for you to say one of those
one night they asked give us an example
just kidding the fastest is up next hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else